le mot viande c'est pas quelque chose
sur lequel évidemment nous en tant que
société gourmet on est on est cramponné
comme vous l'avez rappelé madame la
Présidente on travaille sur une
alternative au foie gras déjà qui est en
lui-même une appellation réglementée
qu'on utilisera bien évidemment pas dans
nos étiquetages de produits on pourra
peut-être y faire référence car il
s'agit d'une alternative mais dans aucun
cas notre produit ne pourra s'appeler
foie gras et on en est conscient et on
accepte complètement cette contrainte
maintenant le l'expérience aussi
gustative de notre produit qui tue je
rappelle et pour rebondir sur les propos
de Monsieur Marx pour nous s'inscrit
dans une forme de savoir-faire dans une
forme de nouvelle tradition en cours de
construction a été développé avec des
chefs avec des personnalités du monde
culinaire dans le cadre de nos
développements de produits et qui ont
quelque part aussi reconnu des
propriétés sensorielles proches du foilà
et de fait à défaut de mieux c'est
compliqué d'imaginer une autre une autre
une autre appellation à court terme
qu'on n'utilisera pas sur nos produits
mais par commodité quand on fait
référence à nos produits c'est celle-ci
qu'on utilise
l'allergie vous l'avez rappelé c'est
fondamental vu que nos cellules elles
partent d'un prélèvement animal que le
consommateur sache qu'il consomme du
poulet de la crevette du canard du bœuf
car originellement il s'agit de
véritables matières animales même si
elle a été produite d'une façon nouvelle
on parle beaucoup d'énergie à la
crevette par exemple c'est fondamental
de savoir sur l'étiquetage que on achète
un produit fait de cette crevette